Mike Myers made the jump from Saturday
Night Live to the big screen with
Wayne's World became a superstar with
Austin Powers and a household name
thanks to Shrek and then he seemed to
pretty much drop off the face of the
earth but why Mike Myers movies and
characters have left a mark on popular
culture that few other comedy stars
could ever hope to match and his ability
to wring laughs from so many different
concepts is legendary so where'd he go
and when can we expect him to make his
eventual comeback here's the real reason
why Hollywood stopped casting Mike Myers
hobbies during his time out of the
spotlight Myers has kept busy with a
number of hobbies ranging from playing
in a floor hockey league twice a week to
Dungeons & Dragons he's a well known
major hockey fan often attending Toronto
Maple Leaf games and sharing his
thoughts on the occasional NHL broadcast
when you're rich and having fun why
bother working if you don't have to but
what I'd really love is to do Wayne's
World for living it might happen
Sharan monkeys might fly out of my butt
directing another big reason Myers
hasn't been in front of the camera in
recent years well he's been spending
time behind it instead in 2014 Myers
directed super bench a documentary about
the life of Shep Gordon a legendary
music manager whose clients ranged from
blondie and Luther Vandross to Alice
Cooper Cooper introduced Gordon to Myers
after making a cameo in Wayne's World
and Gordon has since served as a mentor
to the actor even taking the star into
his home for two months after the death
of Myers his father pigeon-holed Mike
Myers is understandably known as a
comedian first and foremost but while
other comedians such as Robin Williams
were able to transition into serious
roles Myers remains typecast
despite dramatic turns in films like
studio 54 and Quentin Tarantino's
Inglourious Basterds it could be that
Hollywood believes audiences only want
to see Myers cracking jokes preventing
him from exploring his full acting range
flops and bombs for younger audiences
who may not necessarily associate Myers
with Austin Powers or Shrek
there's another movie that unfortunately
comes to mind the Love Guru the 2008
comedy presented Myers as
well a love guru whose dream is to be
featured on The Oprah Winfrey Show he
brought his Austin Powers co-star Verne
Troyer to the film along with several
big names including Justin Timberlake
Jessica Alba and Ben Kingsley but the
film was a massive box-office bomb and a
critical disaster as well
Myers hasn't made a movie since
best-selling author
during his time away from filmmaking
Myers filled his time becoming a
best-selling author penning a book
called Canada the book explores what his
beloved country means to him via
photographs anecdotes and his trademark
humor it was a massive success north of
the border with Myers embarking on a
nationwide promotional tour to celebrate
both his book and his homeland
choosie even if Hollywood wanted to cast
Myers they'd have to come up with a
pretty amazing script to drag him away
from all of his other passions so far
according to Myers they haven't even
bothered trying
he told GQ in 2014 that he had only
received 15 scripts in the last
quarter-century in part because I do
turn virtually everything down given his
reputation at such a tough sell it's no
surprise he hasn't been getting as many
offers as he used to tip it you can't
zip it look always and gentlemen the
jury exhibit a television disappointment
in early 2015 HBO announced Myers had
signed a two-year deal with the network
to make something details were never
specified and the following year it was
reported that Myers eventually opted out
of the contract because his production
deal never led to an order of his series
it's unfortunate that this particular
deal never panned out but it signals
that Myers is interested in returning a
television either as a director producer
or even an actor fatherhood Myers has
also been busy playing a couple of other
major roles husband and father he and
his second wife Kelly Tisdale recently
welcomed a new addition to their family
a daughter named Paulina Kathleen she's
merely the latest in a line of kids that
includes son spike and daughter Sunday
Molly how important is family life to
Myers in an interview with deadline he
said quote anyone who tells you
fatherhood is the greatest thing that
can happen to you
they are understating it I am the
happiest I have ever been in my life I
knew I wanted to be a father I didn't
know it was going to be this awesome or
that my kid would come out so beautiful
and lovely end quote it's tough to
imagine Myers is eager to star in
anything that would take him away from
his family what's next
Mike Myers incredible success with a
string of early hits might have
established unreasonable expectations
for his later efforts but it also gave
him the financial freedom to pick his
projects carefully and that's exactly
what he's done over the last several
years taking the time to indulge outside
interests while waiting on the perfect
script happily for fans that dry spell
may soon come to an end
Myers is attached to return for a fifth
Shrek movie due to arrive in 2019 and
he's also booked another non comedy
signing on to star in the noir thriller
terminal alongside Margot Robbie and
Simon Pegg he's even open to the idea of
a third Wayne's World movie there is
only one thing to say to that young
guard
okay thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]